Before the 2010 reboot film, there was the
original A-Team television series. From 1983
to 1987, the NBC show graced American screens
with guns-a-blazing action and a cast of characters
fans instantly fell in love with. Roll it
all together and toss in some memorable catchphrases,
and it's no wonder The A-Team saw stellar
ratings and gained a cult following. But whatever
happened to the cast that made the show shine
so brightly? Let's get reacquainted with these
'80s acting icons and see what they're up
to now.
George Peppard
With a lovable fierceness and a fat cigar
permanently wedged between his teeth, George
Peppard played team leader Colonel John "Hannibal"
Smith. When The A-Team wrapped in 1987, Peppard
continued acting, popping up in the TV movies
Man Against the Mob and Man Against the Mob:
The Chinatown Murders.
Much like Hannibal, Peppard was a smoker,
a habit that led to his lung cancer diagnosis
in 1992. Sadly, he passed away just two years
later, at the age of 65, after contracting
pneumonia . Just before his death, however,
he finished filming the pilot episode for
a would-have-been Matlock spin-off, The P.I.
Dwight Schultz
As Captain H.M. "Howling Mad" Murdock, Dwight
Schultz catapulted into mainstream fame. Since
then, he's appeared in a few television series,
most notably Star Trek: The Next Generation
and Star Trek: Voyager as Lieutenant Reginald
Barclay. He's also dabbled in film, including
1989's Fat Man and Little Boy and 1996's Star
Trek: First Contact. He even showed up for
a post-credits scene in the A-Team film. From
the late '90s onward, Schultz found his groove
in voice-over work.
Mr. T
We pity the fool who tries to challenge Bosco
Albert "B. A." Baracus, as portrayed unforgettably
by Mr. T. Outside of The A-Team, Mr. T has
gotten into voice acting, appeared on other
mega-popular shows like Diff'rent Strokes,
and even taken a stab at professional wrestling.
Unfortunately, in 1995, he was diagnosed with
T-cell lymphoma, but that hasn't stopped him
from acting. He has specialized in playing
himself, thanks to his big personality and
marketable presence. He can be seen in commercials
for World of Warcraft, Comcast, and Snickers.
"Snickers! Get some nuts!"
While he no longer rocks his signature stacked
gold chains, he's kept the B.A. Baracus mohawk
and thick beard.
Dirk Benedict
Seasoned actor Dirk Benedict played the the
slick, smooth-talking Lieutenant Templeton
"Faceman" Peck. After The A-Team's cancellation,
Benedict appeared in movies like Shadow Force
and Alaska. He even made his directorial and
screenwriting debut in 2001 with the drama
film Cahoots. In 2007, he appeared on the
British version of Celebrity Big Brother.
In the decade since, not much has been seen
of Benedict, though he did make a cameo in
The A-Team film in 2010. Unfortunately, Benedict
wasn't exactly happy with the movie as his
role only lasted a few seconds.
Lance LeGault
While Lance LeGault found substantial stardom
prior to The A-Team, his time as Roderick
Decker earned him a gold star with audiences
around the world. After his work as the gun-wielding
colonel was done, he played another colonel,
this time on Magnum, P.I. He went to guest
star on a variety of other shows, while his
film credits include 1997's Mortal Kombat:
Annihilation and a voice role in Disney's
Home on the Range. Sadly, LeGault passed away
in 2012, although he posthumously appeared
alongside Paul Rudd and Emile Hirsch in the
2013 comedy-drama film Prince Avalanche.
Robert Vaughn
General Hunt Stockwell had a knack for antagonism,
a no-nonsense demeanor, and an ability to
wear a pair of aviator-framed BluBlockers
like nobody's business. Veteran actor Robert
Vaughn slipped into the role with ease, bringing
the formidable bad guy to life in the show's
final season. With an already long list of
acting roles in his resume, Vaughn kept his
momentum at a crazy-fast speed once the show
stopped airing. He took to the stage as Juror
9 in Twelve Angry Men, appeared in a few episodes
of Law & Order, and starred in films like
Motel Blue and Pootie Tang. Vaughn's steadiest
gig following The A-Team, however, was in
the British drama series Hustle, which ran
from 2004 to 2012. After a year-long battle
with leukemia, Vaughn passed away in November
2016, but we have no doubt his acting legacy
will live on for a long time.